Anthony cause II was more than a sports
photographer he was an artist so I'm
constantly thinking how can I tell this
story from a different angle cause II
who shot for the New York Post for 25
years like to quote Mark Twain you can't
depend on your eyes when your
imagination is out of focus Anthony was
an amazingly talented photographer
Yankees great Derek Jeter wrote on
Facebook and he was an even better
person gregarious and humble he was
beloved by athletes and colleagues
Anthony cause II was 48
Jackie Cruz Townes
mother of Minnesota timber wolf star
karl-anthony towns fought a month-long
battle with coronavirus at least our
household is boss Cruz towns who hugged
her son when he was the number one pick
in the 2015 NBA Draft and did not miss a
single game in his first season lost her
battle Monday her passion was palpable
the town's family said in a statement
and her energy will never be replaced
Jacqueline Cruz towns was 58 Bucky
Pizzarelli was a maestro on the guitar a
sought after session musician in the 50s
and 60s he toured with Benny Goodman and
joined the Tonight Show Band when the
show moved to the west coast Pizzarelli
didn't want to up lead his kids so he
began playing in New York nightclubs his
son John would later be one of his
favorite collaborators
[Music]
Bucky Pizzarelli was 94 Judy Wilson
Griffin always knew she wanted to be a
nurse as a girl I would bandage up my
Barbie dolls and all the dolls of my
friends and one day I knew that I would
grow up to help people and she did she
was a nurse with the Navy in the Gulf
War at Saint Mary's Hospital in st.
Louis she handled high-risk pregnancies
and one a March of Dimes nurse of the
Year award last year Judy was the person
we'd be looking to now said Pam lesser
her supervisor and friend a very giving
kind caring soul Judy Wilson Griffin was
63
detective Mary Lou Armour was a 20-year
veteran of the Santa Rosa California
Police Department detective Stefan
Bozell was a longtime friend and worked
with her in the domestic violence and
sexual assault unit
she was an example to other detectives
on how to complete investigations at the
end of the day be a person and show
empathy and professionalism a solemn
procession of 250 police and public
safety vehicles escorted her body to the
cemetery
[Music]
she was a very caring person her sister
Mary Lyall remembered I'm really gonna
miss hugging her detective Mary Lou
Armour was 43 muhammediye 4 came to New
York from Bangladesh in 1991 to make a
better life for his family he took a job
at McDonald's then as a restaurant
delivery man and finally driving a
yellow cab through his hard work his two
sons became the first in the family to
go to college the oldest
maboob Robin graduated City College the
youngest Mahtob Sahab is now at Harvard
it's the immigrants dream come true mon
top said he was so proud Mohammed Jafar
was 56dance Fano was a personal trainer
in Connecticut he owned a gym guys
franchise with his college roommate
Jimmy Bonavita
and friend Sam Langer we were
inseparable Jimmy said he was such a
great spirit said Dan's first client
Mark Brooks he was just so committed we
loved him this is one of his sister
Melissa's favorite memories
[Music]
and singing his favorite song and
another Dan singing again at her wedding
he was utterly infatuated with his
three-month-old niece Adriana
Melissa said it breaks my heart she's
not going to know Uncle Dan Dan Spano
was 30
[Music]
you
[Music]
you